hello uh so today i'll be talking about
a statistical estimation problem
yeah i'll be talking about a statistical
estimation problem and how we use gds
convexity and optimization to solve it
right uh so this is joint work with cole
franks and raphael who are here and then
michael walter to organize a thing but
unfortunately could not be
cool
yes so the plan is i will slowly
introduce some of the words in the title
and then i will very briefly discuss
proof techniques so if you guys have
questions on proof techniques i am very
open to i think i've left time at the
end to ask about that
but
uh no statistical background is
necessary to understand this talk so
i'll go through what these problems are
and then i'll discuss the specific
problem we'll be solving which is the
matrix and tensor normal model cool
so we'll start with what is statistical
estimation is we're given a bunch of
samples from an unknown distribution and
we want to
estimate some concrete property of that
distribution right so that's the general
framework and also in the general
framework
you're given a model so a model is the
family of distributions where the
unknown distribution could come from
right so you don't know everything about
the distribution but you might know
something about it right
and so the running example that we'll be
using over and over is the gaussian
model so you're given a centered
gaussian and unknown covariance right
i'm going to use theta inverse for some
unnecessary technical conditions so
don't worry about that so much but the
point is you don't know covariance but
you know something about the family of
distributions
and now given samples from that division
you want to estimate theta
right so does anyone have any ideas for
a reasonable estimator
okay
yeah cool
empirical preference in this case is
like sort of the only thing
i can think of right it's like the most
reasonable and most straightforward
thing to do uh turns out it's also a
very good estimator and i'll like
quantify what i mean by good but the
point is in this example it's clear what
to do in general it's not clear what a
good estimator is
cool uh or even what good means right
uh but yeah this is sort of the best
known estimator for a gaussian
covariance
now we'll discuss here's a recipe for
coming up with estimators right so
you're given a physical estimation
problem
and let's say you guessed that theta was
the true distribution right so if theta
is the two distribution then you can
look at a pdf of this distribution and
measure how likely the samples were so
using the pdf you say like how likely
was i
uh to come up with exactly these samples
and if that number is small then data's
sort of a bad guess right like it's
unlikely you saw these if that was the
truth
so like flipping that around the maximum
likelihood estimator is
you output the estimator that maximizes
the likelihood so use the pdf as a
likelihood measure and then you pick the
thing that maximizes
so this is an optimization framework for
estimation
right uh once again it's not clear what
good means
uh this is not super important this is
just a bit of a reframing this will show
up later in the problem that we solved
just notice that this is linear in the
first term so it's easybc and this is
convex
so like this is a totally doable
optimization problem
uh and in general this gives a recipe to
find some estimator it's not clear that
the optimizer exists or how good it is
but in our case it'll be useful
cool is everyone clear on maximum
likelihood
uh yeah the best part about this is you
can actually solve this equation you can
like set the derivative to zero and the
inverse covariance just pops out so like
we have formally derived
why we came up with that very reasonable
estimator it is the solution to this
optimization problem
cool
okay now we have some estimator
how do we measure if it's a good
estimator right and so that depends on
the application that depends on like
what properties of the error you care
about in our case we're going to use
this relative error
i'll give some reasons for that later
but
uh intuitively this is like a
multiplicative error so the relative
error between a and b tells you like
uh
b is within one plus minus epsilon times
a something like that uh this thing
comes up in like plus and solvers and
linear system solvers that kind of stuff
any questions
cool and we'll use these two different
norms either for me it's normal or
operator
um it's important to note this is some
sort of like
invariant measure so
it only depends on b to the minus half a
b and minus
uh that'll be
more uh useful when we look at it in
terms of like the positive manifold
there's some sort of like global
invariance that's happening so it's just
measuring it's going to end up measuring
something about the geodesic distance
sort of
um but just keep in mind the environment
and then turns out uh i won't go through
the formulas but the same is true for
this uh the function that we talked
about last time which the mle was a
solution to so that function is
invariant under this like uh
multiplication on on one side
what that means is in order to analyze
how good that estimator is in this
particular relative error we can reduce
to the case where the input came from
the standard gaussian
uh so i won't do that formally but just
imagine that there's like a nice
invariance on both things that makes it
all work out
uh and that's nice because we can use
like awesome concentration properties of
the standard question
and this will come up again when we do
our matrix intestinal model
but with these reductions we have this
like really classical folklore theorem
follows really cleanly from gaussian
concentration so it says when nd is
bigger than d squared over epsilon
squared
you get epsilon error in this sense
for the gaussian covariance estimation
problem
uh i will explain the term up there
right so
on the right hand side you have d
squared which is roughly the number of
free parameters in the unknown thing
right so like how many how many entries
does the matrix have is d squared so you
need sort of that many free variables to
describe it
on the left side when you have n samples
that are dimensional vectors you're sort
of learning nd pieces of information
that's like how i think about it
right uh that intuition will again show
up in our tensor normal model but
importantly
you sort of need at least these samples
to see anything right like if you have
less than d symbols you won't even see
the whole vector space so like your
error could be entirely off right so
there's this sort of known lower bound
you can't do better than this
cool
uh yeah the proof of this is pretty
standard for matrix concentration of
random gaussian vectors
uh yeah and this lower boundary should
keep in mind for our next problem any
questions on this analysis so far
so this analysis will be like the gold
standard which we're going to try and
measure our next problem by like can we
do as good as this
cool so our next problem is the matrix
intensive null model which is in some
sense a generalization of the gaussian
model
so before we describe it let's pretend
that we just have a bunch of random
tensors now so instead of random vectors
we have random tensors
uh as we learned like random tensors are
just a vector in a larger dimensional
space right
and
we learned if these have gaussian
distributions you need at least as many
samples as the big dimension now which
is growing as a product of the little
dimensions right so that is
often quite prohibitively large
right so let's see if we can
think of a good structural assumption
which allows us to bypass this lower map
right
uh and so what the model is this is a
matrix intentional model is you're given
a bunch of samples in a tensor space
and then also the covariance matrix
respects that tensor product structure
so your covariance matrix is just a
tensor product of little pd matrices
that make sense
okay and then in the output now you
don't just want to estimate the whole
covariance you want to actually estimate
the factors like now that i know this is
a structural assumption i want to learn
something about the factors
uh this kind of comes up in any any
application where you can think of a
nice factorization of your data like you
want to learn something about the
individual factors
cool yeah so the two things i could ask
for is like i want
uh the individual factor error to be
small or a weaker uh ask is the whole
thing should be small but i still want
to output something that is a
factorization like this
cool and now like with the same sort of
logic as before we have this intuitive
lower bound so notice what is this sum
of a d squareds
is how many parameters you need to
describe the unknown things
right each d
d a size matrix has d a squared entries
and then on the left side you're getting
n samples of tall d dimensional vectors
right so that's how many pieces of
information you're getting so this is
like what we would aim for to get this
kind of sample complexity and similar
error to what we got in the gaussian
case
uh okay so now
do this first uh
sorry something went wrong in the slides
um so i'm going to talk about an example
of the matrix in our model and sort of
try to explain why this is a
generalization of the gaussian model
right so in the matrix normal model
you're given a bunch of random matrices
right and they come from this kind of a
distribution so
another way to write that is i can just
write it
so you have
x i equals
right so if you have this nice structure
on the covariance another way to say
that is you have a random gaussian
matrix and then you left and right
multiply it by some other matrices
right so a simple factorization okay now
that we have these outputs
note that if i knew the right side right
then this is just estimating the left
side is exactly the gaussian model i was
looking up for a simple way to say that
is every column if you look at it has
covariance that is proportional to theta
l
right
so not exactly
and also for that reason it doesn't
concentrate that well but it's at least
proportional to data
and
if i knew theta r right i could just
right multiply it
and then all my columns are independent
and all my columns are distributed
exactly as they know
so this becomes exactly my like gaussian
model i'm just estimating theta l using
a bunch of independent gaussian vectors
which have covariance data
right so in some sense this is harder
than just estimating the option
and now this sort of presents an idea
for an algorithm
right which is just assume that you know
what data else is for now
and then use the caption idea to
estimate that
r and then go back and forth
so like assume that the theta r is the
right thing and then use the inverse
sample covariance to estimate that l and
then update over and over
right so this is the flip-flop algorithm
this is what was
suggested early on when this model was
proposed and turns out this is
experimentally verified to like converge
really well in practice very quickly
even for the tensor case so in the sense
of case you could imagine i have a
tensor i like assume all my other
margins are correct and fix one et
cetera et cetera
cool
uh yeah so i'll go over some previous
work now
um so the flip-flop algorithm was
proposed
as this model was proposed as a nice way
to think about these
distributions that have some
factorization structure
and it performs really well in practice
right
uh it was known to be as uh consistent
in the asymptotic case meaning when the
number of samples goes to infinity the
estimator converges to the truth where
the estimator is the thing that the
first loft algorithm converges to
right we also don't know what that is at
the moment
uh and then a bunch of other things were
known like we were able to prove
rigorous bounds not we uh people were
able to prove rigorous bounds on the
mean rigor spawns on a few little
moments and nice rigorous bounds when
you have for example sparsity
assumptions or some other like
structural assumptions on your data
more recently there has been some
algebraic approaches to estimating the
threshold when certain estimators exist
or unique that kind of thing so this is
by i think anna segall will give a talk
on this tomorrow uh and then
michael and harm dirksen and uh uh visu
have done some work like exactly
estimating this threshold
uh but no quantitative balance so that's
what's missing right so how do we prove
quantitative error guarantees with
finite samples with no extra structural
assumptions like that's what our work is
about
so that's our main result
is in the tensor normal model
uh this is the only extra constraint
that keeps us away from the standard
gaussian case so we need epsilon to be a
little bit extra small
but other than that
exactly the same error as the standard
gaussian keys comes out so for each
factor we get epsilon error when nd is
bigger than sum over d squared over
epsilon squared which is like
intuitively what you'd expect
right so the only thing missing from
here is like we have a little bit this
only works when it's small enough
cool
the other awesome thing
is we're able to analyze the flip flop
algorithm using our geodesic convex
framework which i haven't discussed yet
but it turns out that it's a natural
descent method in this framework
and so we can analyze why it converges
quickly in practice is because of some
strong effects assumptions that i'll
show later so this exponential
convergence of flip algorithm that we're
rigorously able to prove falls pretty
naturally from this room
so
the two results say
uh the estimator is good and the flip
algorithm converges quickly to the
estimator
cool
uh so
now we can sort of talk about what we do
but in very high level so feel free to
ask questions
unlike the gaussian case it's not clear
what our estimator should be right in
the gap in case there's only sort of one
thing to do
uh here it's not so clear
so then we can use the recipe that we
talked about at the beginning right so
we can try to frame it as a likelihood
estimation problem
so
this is the likelihood function and we
can try to it adds up you minimize this
which is the same as maximizing the pdf
right
uh i want to point out
now this is not so simple like this is
not a linear term there's a bunch of
variables it's
not so clear how to do this optimization
but at least the optimization is like
well formulated
cool
and then how do we do this optimization
we're going to relate this to this
optimization under symmetry workshop and
use geodesic complexity so this function
is really nice
cool
uh yeah so this is going to be
pretty brief but i'll just discuss how
we use js convexity to solve this
problem
okay so we want to optimize this
function
over all positive definite matrices
right
uh and what's natural about positive
definite matrices is that there's these
very nice geodesic curves on positive
images
um one way to think about this is i
think about this as interpolating the
geometric mean
so it's like thinking of the
exponentials and like interpolating
those
right
so you have these curves and then turns
out that our function
uh is
convex along these curves
so this follows from sort of the group
structure that sits underneath this
function
uh and these geodesics also come from
that same group structure so the gfx's
are like naturally derived as shortest
path curves based on something about the
cover in structure
the other nice thing is that the
relative error also relates to shadows
conditions so i'm able to think about
the geodesic capacity to analyze the
function and also to think about the
data connectivity to analyze like
distance in my error
cool so this gives me an idea for what
to do right so i can use this in
variance once again to reduce to the
identity just like i did for the
gaussian case
and then
uh i can analyze some simple properties
of this function right so there's this
thing called the js gradient which is
like what is the regular gradient it
tells me the first order differential
that i need direction but the g s
gradient is telling me the first order
differential along my dss curves
right so i can use gaussian
concentration to show that the gs
gradient is small meaning i'm like close
to a critical point
and then because i am convex along
geodesics a critical point is also the
global optimum
right so my starting point is close to a
critical point which is also global
and so i just need to solve for this
optimum of this
uh convex function
uh there has been some work done on
these kind of jets comics functions in
this particular setting
right by uh peterborough and his god
there's some of whom are here uh
unfortunately these so these are for
worst case results which require really
small initial error
and only give kind of poor bounds on the
distance so we'll try to improve that
using strong convexity that's our main
plan
uh and so how do we do this we can use a
really nice result of physia to lower
bound the hessian which is like what's
wrong with x it is right so this is like
pretty straightforward once you have
this nice powerful result to pizza so
you look at the second order and you
lower bound the terms
um this allows us to show that the
function is geodesically strongly convex
right which means maybe we can prove
something stronger about distance to
optimum and stuff right uh if like the
function is curving away from the album
and then not only is the strong convex
of the identity but you can use just
sort of turn-by-term analysis on the
hessian to show that the hessian doesn't
change that much in a small ball so
let's draw the convex in a small ball
around the starting point
right
meaning if your initial gradient is
small
and it's strongly convex near where you
are right you're going to reach the
album quickly
that's the idea
uh
like to do this formally we need to do
uh beyond worst case analysis of tensor
scaling which is what this ends up being
intense scaling is part of the scaling
framework that you analyze using this
geodesic comic
uh but once we have that we have like a
nice distance bound for the animal
any questions
very open questions to talk about
techniques
you want to say that like somehow the
more samples you have like the idea is
that it the problem becomes kind of more
strongly complex right
that's the idea why kind of
these results can hold right right
uh so
yeah the the way like you very quickly
get stronger if you have strong
convexity
basically like that one condition that i
had that makes us different from the
gaussian model that you don't even need
that just you guys wrong
but in order for your
gradient to converge fast enough you
need lots of samples like uh
the initial gradient is related to the
initial concentration right so the more
cycles you have the like smaller the
initial variation
and then you need it to be so small that
the strong complexity wins out sort of
which is why you need that extra
position on this one but that's what the
extra samples help you do is it shrinks
the radiation
yeah i have a question
so for this causing knowing all the
things there are identifiability we
should you see that once you have two
objects
yeah
so in the paper we just fix the
dimension which is like all the things
that people determine
another way to do is to separate the
determinant part out so you take out a
scalar record make sure you show your
determinant
which fits a little better in this group
framework because now you're optimizing
over sl
yeah it's just a convention uh it's not
like
i think some people in literature do
different things
and it's just not by scalars and you
could sort of guess the scale idea
okay so now i can talk about some
problems or like what is remaining um
right so as i said
our main theorem is just one dimension
back away from matching the gaussian
model so it would be nice to remove that
constraint
um
in the paper we were able to give
slightly refined bounds for the matrix
normal model and also like for the
tensorflow model we can decrease the
sample capacity a little bit uh the
second one is my thesis if you guys are
curious
uh
okay so that's more directly what the
other problems are
and then sort of more generally
there's very simple generalizations of
this that we don't know how to do
anything for right so we suggested one
one suggestion is like instead of just
one product it's like the sum of two
products or k products or whatever like
none of this framework exactly fits
anymore it's not clear what to do
even though that's a pretty natural
assumption for your data right
uh and then the second one is as i guess
melanie we'll talk about later
more general algorithms for like
geodesic components automation as a
whole like that's a well studied and
also well-motivated problem from a lot
of perspectives
so we used a pretty simple algorithm and
simple analysis but
in a very special case right so can you
think of more general things
cool that's all
this
saving you is that uh with enough
samples at your threshold uh you can say
that
the gradient uh your initialization will
have small gradients
quickly right right
but uh a priori you could ask for like a
voice like
like
with a smaller sample complexity you
still want to start off far farther off
but
still argue that right yeah which would
be the general problem
[Music]
but that's why our technique
may exist but he may not be close to the
true distribution
i see right
so because they're like in this sense
like this here doesn't say anything
about the algorithm they're just telling
you how close the mle
is to the actual distribution right
because if you don't have enough samples
you wouldn't expect with high
probability
exactly exactly right so that's what we
are going to prove
but
uh yeah
any other questions
[Applause]
is